video has surfaced of a Donald Trump
judicial nominee for district judge in
DC it is one of the most cringe-worthy
and also disturbed disturbing
confirmation hearing videos that I've
ever seen this guy's name this guy right
here over my shoulder is Matthew Spencer
Peterson he was nominated to be a judge
by Trump like I said and his
confirmation hearing goes bad quickly
and the cringe factor is so high that I
would not let kids watch this
I would not allow kids in the room when
you're if you're gonna watch this it
starts off really poorly senator John
Kennedy who's a Republican don't be
fooled by the last name Kennedy he asked
panel members to raise their hands if
they have never tried cases in a
courtroom only Peterson raises his hand
which brings on a series of follow-ups
each becoming even more awkward take a
look at this welcome gentlemen
congratulations you can just raise your
hand on this one if you will to save a
little time have any of you not tried a
case to verdict in a courtroom mr. page
have you ever tried a jury trial I have
not
Sybil no criminal no bench no state our
federal court I have not have you ever
taken a deposition I was involved in
taking depositions when I was associate
at why the Ryan when I first came out of
Law School
yeah there you go so already it's going
it's going south but this is one of the
best videos I've seen a few more
questions and it only gets worse for
Peterson if you ever try to taking a
deposition by yourself
I believe No okay have you ever argued a
motion in state court I have not have
you ever argued a motion in federal
court No
when's the last time you read the
Federal Rules of Civil Procedure the
Federal Rules of Civil Procedure I in my
current position I obviously don't need
to stay as you know invested in those on
a day to day basis but I do try to keep
up to speed we do have at the Federal
Election Commission roughly 70 attorneys
yeah who work under our our guidance
have you ever hard boiled an egg no the
hearing goes forward and then Republican
senator Kennedy from Louisiana asks
about some of the basics of evidence
rules and some legal doctrines and there
was a debate over whether these were
fair questions or really obscure legal
stuff I'll deal with that after we watch
the video well as a trial judge you're
obviously going to have witnesses yes
you tell me what the dough bear standard
is senator Kennedy I don't have that
readily at my disposal but I would be
happy to take a closer look at that okay
that that is not something that I've had
to do you know what a motion in limine
is yes I haven't I'm again my background
is not in litigation as as when I was
replying to chairman Grassley I haven't
had to again do a deep dive and I and I
and understand and and I appreciate this
that this line of questioning I
understand I'm sure you do it that goes
on for about 90 seconds and then Kennedy
tries one more time that's I've been a
party to during my time yes sir I've
read your resume
just for the record do you know what a
motion in limine is I would probably not
be able to give you a good definition
right here at the tip I'll say table do
you know what the younger abstention
doctrine is oops about to pull Minnie
in doctrine I don't see you all see that
a lot just in federal yeah Bill Pullman
from he was the president an
independence day that was when he went
after the aliens with Will Smith wasn't
it just utterly destroyed so first
question is were these fair questions or
is it like saying can you tell me what
the square root of three billion two
hundred fifty three million is is it of
any value or importance that he doesn't
know this stuff or is it basic legal
material unquestionably the consensus of
legal experts is that this guy should
have known this stuff he respond that he
hasn't been working in litigation but a
motion in limine it's just a basic issue
of asking judges to decide about
evidence that will or won't be permitted
at trial doe bear is a basic issue of
how judges decide whether specific
scientific testimony is reliable enough
for the court the younger and Pullman
doctrines if he knows the least that
most lawyers know who even don't work in
these areas he'd be able to say well it
relates to federal courts resolving
issues not resolving issues out of
deference to state courts these are
really general things you can be a good
lawyer and not know this stuff but you
can't be a credible nominee to be a
federal court judge if you don't know
this and I don't know if I even blame
him that much I'm more blame the Trump
administration for nominating him he
should not be nominated that's exactly
right
just look online at the comments from
the attorneys and legal scholars they
all say many attorneys don't know this
stuff but they're not sitting there at a
confirmation hearing to be appointed for
life to positions as federal judges and
the problem of course is that lots of
Trumpets don't see this as a problem
they see this as hey it's a regular guy
which is of course laughable he's a
highly paid guy who did campaign finance
law at a major DC law firm but there's a
part of this country that sees this and
says that's right that's Trump pudding
just average people there he doesn't
know anything yeah I mean if there's one
thing I know about Trump he wasn't
really qualified to be President but he
was going to get the best people for the
job to work for him - yep in the courts
that that certainly is not happening and
some of those people have already lost
their jobs fortunately disaster
discussed the square this on our
subreddit at david pakman.com slash re d
di t today's program is made possible
in part by Gamefly which is sort of like
netflix for video games they've got over
8,000 new and classic games for xbox one
Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of
other platforms and you can also stream
games you don't even need a gaming
console or a computer because you can
stream games through your Amazon fire
stick or Roku box and then use your
mobile phone as the controller you can
play as many games as you want for one
monthly fee and if you find some games
you want to keep you can buy them for a
low used price never with due dates or
late fees and our audience can get a
30-day free trial at Gamefly offer.com
slash TDP s the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included no contracts and you can also
stream the games I think I mentioned
that you can also rent games through the
mobile app get a free 30 day trial for
david pakman show viewers and listeners
and support our show at Gamefly
offer.com forward slash TDP s